hola de nuevo cómo están bienvenidos de
nuevo estamos en el examen número 7 en
la sección número 2 y estamos
resolviendo el problema número 3 y dice
a una compañía de globos venden bolsas
de globos de colores verde rojos o
azules
elena y el enano su nombre en definitivo
que se parezca el mío
elena compró una caja con globos ok bien
está ahí en la cual un tercio de ellos
son rojos vamos a ponerlo con color rojo
un tercio de ellos son rojos ok
y después dice si la cantidad de globos
de color verde es un medio de la
cantidad de globos de color rojo ok la
cantidad de globos de color verde verde
es lo mismo que un medio que un medio lo
voy a poner también de color verde la
cantidad de globos de color rojo
ok y después nos dicen que hay 18 globos
azules la cantidad de globos azules
azules si sabemos cuánto es es lo mismo
que 18 muy bien cuántos globos había en
total en la caja
ok
imagínate que
tenemos una caja completa de hecho
tenemos una caja completa la cual un
tercio son rojos y un medio de la
cantidad de rojos es verde cuántos un
medio de un tercio bueno pues un medio
un medio por la cantidad de globos que
hay que son un tercio de la caja total
por un tercio es lo mismo que un sexto
un sexto de la cantidad total de globos
que hay son globos de color verde ok
visto como fracción cuál es la cantidad
de globos de color azul
bueno pues realmente me tendría que
tomar a un tercio que es la cantidad de
globos de color rojo a esto sumarle un
sexto que es la cantidad de globos que
hay de color
verde ya esto me voy a tomar la
diferencia de 1 - la suma de estos dos
para saber la fracción o el porcentaje
de la cantidad de globos azules que hay
y cuántos esto bueno pues esto es lo
mismo que 1 - y cuantos un tercio más un
sexto el mínimo común múltiplo de 63
cabe dos veces en seis por un 22 más uno
y esto es igual a 1 - 3 sextos que es lo
mismo que uno menos un medio que es lo
mismo que uno
ok ya sabemos cuántos globos azules hay
de hecho en la caja la mitad de los
globos son azules un tercio de los
globos son rojos y un tercio no un sexto
de los globos son verdes un medio son
azules un tercio son rojos un sexto son
verdes pero tenemos 18 azules sin la
mitad de la cantidad de los globos que
en la caja son 18 ok entonces el total
de globos de globos que hay en la caja
pues es 18 por 2 o cuales 36 la mitad es
18 ya podemos ver que 12 logos son rojos
12 globos son rojos porque es un tercio
de 36 y además ya podemos ver que seis
globos eran de color verde de color
verde tenemos seis globos y si tus más
doce más seis las 18 sean 36 los totales
y además se junte que la mitad de los
globos totales eran los globos azules
que son 18 perfecto entonces mi
respuesta es 36 así que borremos la
pantalla
y ahora vamos a trabajar con el problema
número 14 cambiamos herramienta el
problema número 14 y dice tres puntos
distintos
p q r viven en la recta l por otra parte
cuatro puntos todos distintos stv viven
en la recta que es diferente a la venta
l pero es paralela a l a ver tenemos dos
rectas la recta l esta es mi recta l y
tengo otra recta que es paralela a l
este de aquí y por cierto a supongamos
que ésta se llama lm voy a poner a esta
nombre m y en la recta el lema vive en
tres puntos distintos es pq r por aquí
está por aquí está aquí y por aquí vive
r tengo tres puntos distintos y en la
web y en la recta paralela que no es l
es decir m viven cuatro puntos distintos
que es st por aquí tengo a ese por aquí
tengo
por aquí tengo a un y por aquí tengo ave
no sé qué son distintos y lo que me
preguntan es cuál es el número de rectas
distintas que se pueden formar usando
exactamente exactamente es una palabra
muy importante dos puntos de estos siete
mencionados ok
si yo agarro dos de estos puntos y hago
una recta esta recta va a estar entre
las rectas que voy a contar por ejemplo
ese q es una recta que pasa por
exactamente dos puntos de estas rectas y
de hecho ya te puedes dar cuenta que qt
también es una de ellas que q también es
una de ellas que bq también es una de
ellas y de igual manera para p y para r
ahora es lo que quiero que te des cuenta
es que tanto la recta l como la recta m
no forman parte de estas rectas que
vamos a contar y l&m no forman parte de
estas rectas porque aunque tienen dos
puntos y es una recta que pasa por dos
puntos de estos mencionados no pasan por
esa realmente dos puntos pasan en el
caso de l por tres y pasan en el caso de
emma por cuatro no por exactamente dos
puntos por lo tanto el menos tal está en
la recta que pasa por qs por qt por q
por cuba y también podemos hacer lo
mismo con pe pp aunque también está ps
aunque también está perú ok
también está
pero también está pp ok de aquí tenemos
otras cuatro y también podemos hacer lo
mismo con r fijarnos en r s algo así en
tr algo así en un ere también algo así y
en p r también algo así y si te das
cuenta tengo 4 con p 4 con wu y cuatro
con él es decir que en total tengo 12
rectas distintas las puedes pasar por
exactamente dos puntos de estos
mencionados p q r s t weaver entonces mi
respuesta es 12 tened cuidado aquí lo
más importante es que no contemos a l m
y recuerda que no las contamos porque
pasan por más de 2 puntos
ok problema número 14 vamos a inventar a
ser problema número 15
déjame cambiar de color y pongamos una
nueva capa problema número 15 si 2
elevado a la x + 2 elevado a la equis
2 elevado a la x + 2 elevado a la x 1 2
3 4 1 2 3 4 ok esto es igual a 2 elevado
a las 7 lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale x ok aunque te parece si
actualizamos un 2 a la x una vez que dar
2 a la x es más vamos a sumar los dos a
la x + 2 a la x + 2 a la x + 2 a la x
esto es 4 veces 2 a la x 4 x 2 a la x es
lo mismo que 2 elevado a las 7 y bueno
podremos calcular cuántos 12 las 7 y
dividirlo entre 4 pero recuerda que el 4
lo podemos ver como potencias de 2 esto
es lo mismo que 2 al cuadrado por 2 a la
equis esto es igual a 2 a las 7 y si
tenemos la misma base utilizando las
leyes los exponentes que son súper
importantes me va a quedar que 2 tengo 2
al cuadrado por 2 a la equis esto es lo
mismo que 2 y las potencias se suman x2
2 elevado al x + 2 debe de ser igual a 2
a la 7 y de aquí ya podemos decir que x
+ 2 debe de ser igual a 7 para que se
cumpla esta igualdad y de aquí ya
podemos despejar la x x es igual a 5 y
ya está esta es la respuesta a este
problema no estaba tan difícil parecía
muy rimbombante sonaba muy difícil pero
realmente si sumamos 2 a la x + 2 a la x
+ 2 a la x + 2 a la x estamos tomándonos
4 veces 2 a la x y de aquí bueno
recordar que el 4 lo podemos ver como
potencias de 2 problema número 15 muy
bien vamos a hacer el siguiente problema
problema número 16 y dice cada una de
cinco personas distintas tiene una
tarjeta en blanco ok le doy a cinco
personas distintas una tarjeta en blanco
y en la cual van a escribir un entero
positivo en cada una de esas tarjetas va
a escribir un entero positivo si el
promedio de los números de las tarjetas
es 15
cuál es el posible número más grande que
se pueda escribir en una de las tarjetas
ok vamos con calma imagínate que
escriben 5 enteros positivos ojos
enteros enteros positivos esto me va a
servir
positivos y se escriben a 50 los
positivos distintos supongamos x 1 x 2
x 3
x 4 y x 5 estos son los números que se
escribieron en las tarjetas y todos son
entre los positivos dice si yo me tomo
el promedio de estos 5 es decir si a
éste le sumo este después de sumo este
después de su muerte después le sumo
este y a todo esto lo divido entre la
cantidad de números que hay 5 esto va a
ser igual a 15 es lo que me dice el
problema por ciento de aquí podemos
despejar ya de una manera muy rápida
cuando es a x1
+ x2 + x 3 más x 4 + x 5 esto es lo
mismo que 5 x 15 lo cual es 50 + 25
75 ok la suma de los cinco números que
se escribieron en las tarjetas en blanco
que son enteros positivos me debe de dar
75 lo que me preguntan es cuál es el
posible número más grande que se pueda
escribir en una de las tarjetas ok vamos
a forzar a uno de estos números a que
sea el más grande y se me antoja
que sea x 1 voy a decir que x 1 es el
más grande que se puede escribir en las
tarjetas y es el más grande por lo tanto
de estos 5 números entonces qué te
parece si lo despejamos aquí x 1 es
igual a 75 a este de aquí y esto lo voy
a pasar de otro lado restando con signo
negativo o les voy a restar de ambos
lado de la ecuación de tal manera que me
va a quedar 75 menos x 2 - x 3
2 x 4 - x 5 y seguramente te estás
preguntando por qué estoy haciendo todo
esto porque estoy despejando x1 bueno
porque ello es lo que quiero saber es
cuál es el valor más grande que puede
tomar x1 y el valor más grande que pueda
tomar x1 es lo mismo que 75 quitándole
estos números pero como queremos que x1
sea lo más grande lo más grande posible
pues lo que vamos a intentar es quitarle
lo menos posible a 75 dicho de otra
manera vamos a intentar quitar x 2 x 3 x
4 y x 5 que sean los números más
pequeños posibles que se pueda cumplir
con ellos y bueno lo que tenemos es que
tanto x 2 y eso es muy importante ya que
está la clave y ya casi tenemos la
solución tanto x 2 como x 3 como x 4
como x 5 deben de ser enteros positivos
eso es lo que me dice el problema deben
de ser enteros positivos entonces a un
mínimo que pueden valer es
un excelente lo positivo más pequeño y
bueno pueden valer muchísimo pero como
queremos que x1 sea lo más grande
posible entonces qué te parece si
hacemos a x 2 x 3 x 4 y x 5 valgan lo
menos posible lo más pequeño que se
pueda entonces voy a decir cada uno vale
1 es decir que esto es lo mismo que 75
menos voy a decir que x 2 vale 1 si x2
vale 1 recuerda que es un entero
positivo y es el más pequeño posible voy
a pensar que x 3 también vale uno
recuerda que no es ninguna restricción
del problema que me digan que deben de
ser entre los distintos entonces voy a
decir que valen lo menos posible también
1 x 4 pues también voy a decir que vale
1 y x 5 también voy a decir que vale 1 y
fíjate que cumplen que son enteros
positivos ok y cuando es esto bueno pues
75 -1 74 menos 173 72 71 es decir que lo
más grande que puede valer x es 71 y en
este caso nosotros en de los positivos
que se escribieron las tarjetas en
blanco
en 1 1 1 y 1 pero ya está el entero más
grande que se puede escribir en nuestras
tarjetas el 71 tal que se cumplan que el
promedio de los cinco sea 15 y bueno me
faltan dos problemas y ya me quedé sin
tiempo así que lo resolvemos en el
siguiente vídeo hasta la próxima